You could sweat at anytime. Really, anytime.
You have to walk somewhere, you're warm.
Upstairs maybe? You're moist. You have to carry something too? You're f****** sweating.
Coffee makes you sweat. Iced coffee makes you sweat.
If there's a strap on you, you're gonna sweat a little bit extra right where that strap is.
Sitting in a chair makes your back sweat. You avoid raising your arms because doing so would reveal just how sweaty you are.
You may have googled hyperhidrosis and then wondered just how sweaty does a person need to be in order to have a medical sweating condition
You've perfected the shirt fluff technic to help air yourself out even though it does nothing.
You've been asked seriously, 'is it raining out?' and jokingly, 'hey is it raining out?' Fuck that second person.
Sometimes you'll wear layers to hide how sweaty you are but that just makes you warmer and sweatier and eventually you have to take off that layer.
and reveal that you're now the sweatiest you've ever been. And thinking about how sweaty you are makes you nervous about how sweaty you are which just makes you sweat even more
*huff* But it's fine because, every body sweats, just some people are a little better at it than others.